who wants to talk about money that's me
peg doll the maroon suit and your shoes
may not tell you this but I'm a hustler
I wouldn't screw you over I'm a Bills
fan friends in here I'm gonna break your
tiny little ass in to stop trying not to
be poor and start trying to get rich
what's the difference between a hooker
and a debt collector
I like this joke I hope it takes your
money before screwing yet
are you a debt collector like relieving
people with the burden of death there's
an amazing feeling you get when you find
your true calling
clear your deck will decrease your
stress which will absolutely increase
your milk supply it was time to become
my own boss always thinking bigger
bigger we were taking it in hallelujah -
defied sister they're shaking in their
boots because they know we're the best
and we're gonna put them out of business
this is war
you think it's time you settle down not
in my two decades on this earth have I
ever seemed like the settlement I know
your stress
oh gosh if it had to be war I was gonna
win it no intimidation
[Music]
are you trying to go back to prison
[Music]
[Music]
why didn't you tell me about this little
angel
[Music]
you